how are you DJ I'm doing great rich you
know there was a scout no lie from the
WWE at the Senior Bowl tell me about it
seriously really I think you even said
on his credential WWE because they had
made their announcement yeah okay so I'm
talking to one of my buddies who's got
what a team he was just talking to him
and he was like yeah you guess they
started to work on these guys and so
then we started having fun a bunch of
personnel guys just going back and forth
about kind of like coming to America the
NFL has the Giants we have the Andre the
Giant I mean wow so was it was did the
guy have a nickname on his credentials
it means a stone cold or was it I didn't
get to meet him but I just heard that
they're off on their work man
Daniel Jeremiah working on the
first-ever XFL 2.0 mock draft 1.0 the
game this is a great game there's nobody
at the Senior Bowl named Cena is there
very good all right who is showing up
there who's shown out so far DJ anyone
well I think Baker
I thought Baker had a great week you
know that was probably the headliner and
I know people think we focus too much on
the quarterbacks but he was outstanding
he was consistent the most consistent
guy kind of throughout the week and he
just looks comfortable and confident
he's so quick and now I'm just talking
about feet but just working through your
progressions and final order to put the
football he processes really really
quickly so he he was impressive I
thought Josh Allen got better every day
culminating with his practice yesterday
especially down in the red zone was
really good he's going to take some time
but I think the you know look the upside
is is what it is it's it's very very
intriguing so he I thought where he came
in I think he probably leaves in about
the same area I don't know that he
helped hurt himself and then I thought
the quarterback that probably helped
himself more than anybody else was Luke
fault because he's kind of been out of
sight out of mind and playing a bowl
game he was injured but he came out here
and what I doesn't have a big
which is very efficient and every year
it seems like we get a third fourth
round quarterback out of this out of
this game that ends up he'd be the one
to keep an eye on okay so as anybody
hurt themselves not physically but you
know stock wise this week well before
yesterday I would have said Marcus
Davenport the end from from San Antonio
was not having a great week was a little
disappointing but then yesterday in the
team period he had two sacks and then
had another time where he kind of tipped
the ball out of his hand that that got
picked so he ended up having a big day
there and you know this is man we see
this every year you'll see some of the
guys in the practices there so so and
then we get to the game on Saturday and
they rip it up so you hate to make any
strong declarations until they get a
chance to play tomorrow sure Daniel
Jeremiah joining me here I'll ask you
the question I asked our buddy Bucky
Brooks a couple days ago is the first
overall selected quarterback currently
in Mobile Alabama yea or nay what do you
think well I mean I've only pretty much
been in my hotel on the chick-fil-a next
door but I haven't so I don't think so
what a great response DJ that's a good
my wife looked at my wife looked at the
credit card bill the other day she goes
I keep there's just like a seven dollar
dinner charge every night how much money
do they give you for dinner convenient
it's convenient yeah convenience you
know that's what it's all about okay so
you'd you still think Donald's one I saw
in your first mock draft that you had
the Giants passing on Josh Rosen taking
sacrum Barca and Rosen falling to the
Jets
if that happens DJ not only would you be
Nostradamus
but that would set up a storyline in the
New York City football media for a
decade plus for a decade plus Daniel I
did it for the rich ahead and show very
happy if Josh Rosen a Magette do you
really you're thinking behind all of
that DJ yeah look it to me it's it's
gonna be fascinating that the real
decision I think comes in at number two
is what Giants do and it's one of
they're gonna be on
one of two tracks we are in full rebuild
looked at the future mood or we have
Dave gentlemen back in the building who
was around when Eli won a couple rings
and still thinks that Eli's got a little
bit left and he thinks man we get Odell
Beckham back healthy I go out and get
him steak Juan Barkley and then we can
flip this thing right back around be in
the playoffs next year so it's just kind
of one of those two lines of thinking so
on this one you know you'll deal Tory
around different scenarios doing these
mock drafts but this one this is the eli
skittle got a little left mock draft
theory well that would be a I mean this
would be a dream Jay Z scenario to have
say Kwan right there and right there in
his backyard and in the New York City
metropolitan area but you think Rosen
would fall past any other quarterback
needy teams like say Denver I mean
Denver is getting a look-see at both
Mayfield and Alan because they're
coaching the Senior Bowl so what do you
think there well the vibe and again I
try and do these mock drafts a lot of
what I'm kind of hearing a buzz and it's
not like there's kind of that right now
but you do hear a lot about the Broncos
and out there probably one of those
teams that's gonna look pretty hard at
the veteran market yeah I mean who'd
that consists of and I know Alex Smith
ain't getting traded there inside the
division so that leaves you with Kirk
Cousins if he does get to the market and
I think there's a lot of people
connecting the dots to think if if he is
a free agent that Denver would be a very
likely landing spot III agree I think
Kirk Cousins with those weapons in that
in that area with with that offense that
they could you know tailor around him
that would be something I think that
would work
don't you Daniel they have veteran yes
some veteran receivers that he would
immediately become cool with I mean I
still feel like it's weird I know he's
gotten all this money from being tagged
and all that but I still feel like he's
kind of he doesn't get the full buy-in
from people on the outside but on the
inside when you around people in the
league I think there's a lot of respect
for what Kirk Cousins has done and they
realize he had been throwing to to Jerry
Rice out there the last couple years a
couple more minutes here with Daniel
Jeremiah calling in from the Senior Bowl
so well we got Nick Saban in the booth
huh that was pretty cool what about that
well what a doe what did you glean
from what he was talking about with our
POS and how he thinks it's making things
exciting at the professional level that
the NFL is taking more and more from
college and clearly you know what Nick
Foles has been doing over the last two
playoff games with all those rpoS has
the Eagles in the Super Bowl
what did you take from Nick's comments
well I thought he was I thought it was
right on you know it's funny cuz you
just down here talking about and it's
you know the I think a little bit of a
narrative it's you know the hey the
Eagles are really you know they're
really dabbling in the in the RPO world
they're really mixing that in and you're
down here it's like mixing it in it's
their whole offense their entire offense
the Eagles are running is a college
offense and they're one game away from
winning the Superbowl with this college
often so I think it's a little bit of a
turning point
you saw what Watson was doing with
Houston and you got to kind of rearrange
your thinking as an evaluator and just
say hey not this is not something where
they're sprinkle in the stuff and
there's a full commitment taking place
to this style of football and it's gonna
make guys like Baker Mayfield a heck of
a lot more valuable huh so what do you
think Bella checks gonna do here I mean
cuz Mariucci came on our Monday show and
said he wouldn't be surprised if he
called Saban up to say hey what are you
seeing out of these rpoS all the time
that can help us defensively how do you
think he is spending his time in the
film room with the future coach of the
Detroit Lions on how to stop this thing
yeah I mean I think sure you make that
phone call here is it here's the
challenge though because Saban can give
them all the advice about what they do
schematically but Saban's 11 dudes on
defense are better than the 11 Dukes on
offense they play every single week that
Patriots defense right is not they are
not so that's gonna be the big challenge
that front seven especially those
linebackers they're gonna have to be
sorting through all that stuff you talk
well use the term eye candy I mean
they're gonna have to sort through all
that they're gonna stretch those guys
all over the place mentally and
physically who do you think on the
Eagles defense could start for the crack
the lineup for the Patriots I mean or
vice versa so give me Patriots that
could crack that line up in the Eagles
defense Daniel yeah I still come back to
two McCourty you know but that's you
know that's if you're talking about
McLeod
I take Jenkins over him
so you've got McCourty in the mix and
then flowers would be in the rotation
but outside of that and you can't find a
lot of guys so do you deal with so you
think the Eagles can win the are going
to win this game what do you think I
think they've got a really good shot you
know I just have a hard fashioned rule
I'd never ever bet against number 12 yep
because everything else is stacking some
else's favor you get to that position
the most important position in the guy
stuff he's a freak show so I don't I
don't have to have it every bet against
number 12 but if you just look at it on
paper yes I can make a case eagles gonna
win this one all right DJ thanks for the
call enjoy the the rest of your
chick-fil-a Palooza and I guess a fish
if you see a Scout take a bridge chair
to somebody you know that that's the one
from the WWE right oh this is gonna be
so fun wait all right Daniel we'll see
you soon okay but that's a DJ hat move
the sticks for more Rich Eisen show
tuned - audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
or download the Rich Eisen show app